[Music]
ya're Jennifer Paris was hanging it with
another really hot guy for himself Chris
Hemsworth
when does Chris Hemsworth feel his
sexiest sexiest I don't know when my
wife tells me I am that's the answer you
get from the family man Chris is happily
married to model and actress Elsa Pataky
who is always posting adorable photos of
Chris and their three kids what does she
bring out universe
she makes me enjoy it you know she makes
me kind of just go just just you've
worked your ass off now have fun enjoy
it that's exactly what he's doing
shooting for Thor Ragnarok has wrapped
and Chris says it's the best one yet
it's a long story
you've got the new trailer coming out
soon which I saw quietly secretly
yesterday and it is insane and amazing
[Applause]
he's also the new face of Hugo Boss and
their boss bottle with Dora where this
fragrance of course
he's not usually one to dress up he
prefers boardshorts to tuxedo shirts but
there are limits to dressing down as his
brother Liam fruits this week
Leon posted this amazing photo the other
day of him in his abs it's teeny tiny
shorts that felt like a light fraud I
not drunk ins done it post and then the
following morning's like I didn't did I
I can't believe that now it was like
it's unintentional
no chance of you doing that man you're a
jerk
all right exactly and thor ragnarok
opens November 3rd yammerin matheson
here with me now and you r on that set i
was it is gonna be amazing we'll have
that for you before the movie premieres
for sure
[Music]
Oh